[Música]
como ésta puebla
como vamos a las dos personas de tinte
que aplaudieron gracias
pues bueno quería hablarles un poquito
de estar hiperconectados qué quiere
decir esto así nos vemos nosotros como
ven en pantalla
hoy por hoy siempre nos vemos así todo
el mundo hablando entre sí pero a la
hora de la verdad se están mandando
textos o whatsapp y todo el mundo está
en su cuento entonces el mundo ha
cambiado muchísimo no hablamos mucho de
los millennials ahora vamos a hablar de
los indians que son la generación z que
ya está tomando y creció con toda esta
tecnología entonces vamos a hablar de
qué quiere decir 5g primero que todo
para que podamos cuadrar no sé que es
nuestra tecnología para dónde vamos y
qué quiere decir entonces todo el mundo
me pregunta sobre 5g pero normalmente
cuando hablamos de 5g tiene un poco
donde cambios tecnológicos pero para un
usuario normal como yo que quiere decir
5g cómo se va a traducir en lo que yo
hago todos los días yo les quería dar un
pequeño resumen de lo que es
la palabra mágica de todo esto es
latencia que es latencia latencia es el
retardo del entrega de paquetes de
información que nos manda una red
entonces hoy por hoy en tecnología 4g o
4g lte como pueden ver se demora 100
milisegundos en llegar la información en
4g lte 20 milisegundos cuando tengamos
la tecnología 5g
esa tecnología se va a demorar de 1 a 2
milisegundos porque es importante eso
el carro que se maneja solo esos carros
que están haciendo exámenes alrededor
del mundo entero que se manejan solos
por todas partes
si la latencia es muy grande y se demora
mucho en bajar esa información que
tenemos el problema que vamos a tener es
que lo puede atropellar aún al carro no
cuando el relojito está haciendo así en
el teléfono sino explicó no yo no quiero
ser el que está cruzando la calle y de
pronto no está conectado a la red bien y
está haciendo así que caigo yo no
atropellado eso es la latencia la
latencia nos va a ayudar muchísimo a
nivel a que la tecnología llegue y
podemos ver cómo va a cambiar la
educación va a cambiar todo en el mundo
entonces hablemos de lo que es educación
formación y cultura es súper importante
que esta información información la
empecemos a manejar mejor el mundo ha
cambiado muchísimo con esto entonces
podemos ver estos cambios culturales que
tenemos entonces número uno el acceso a
la información
es completamente distinto a cuando yo
estaba creciendo en los 80s a mí me
tocaba ir había unos libros grandes en
las bibliotecas así gigantescos se
llaman enciclopedias para los cilenia
lxii los millennials y uno tenía que
sacar el libro y hacer sacar toda la
información y con eso podía trabajar no
hacer las tareas y este tipo de cosas
hoy por hoy no la nueva generación se
mete va en línea baja las respuestas o
la información
y con eso presentan los exámenes y todas
las aplicaciones una que se llama photo
matt lo que yo puedo hacer todos los
ejercicios de matemáticas le pongo eso y
me muestra cómo llego a la respuesta una
cosa increíble no no iría uno de mis
compañeros de trabajo una cosa
fantástica que podemos utilizar pero el
problema del acceso a la información
inmediata es que la formación nos está
dando de la misma forma que se daba
antes
entonces yo puedo bajar cualquier tipo
de información pero al bajar esa
información tengo muchos problemas cuál
es el primer problema que nadie me está
diciendo si la información es correcta o
no porque lo que pasa con el internet
hoy por hoy vídeo todas las redes
sociales es que hay información que es
real es la básica no en la que nos dan
definiciones y las cosas que están
pasando y hay otra información que da
como ciertos de nosotros y viene con una
editorial donde están dictando a uno
básicamente su opinión dentro de eso y
uno como lo está bajando el internet lo
está tomando como si fuera ciento por
ciento cierto eso nos genera un problema
terrible porque yo a veces puedo estar
pensando que estoy en lo correcto pero
estoy trabajando con la opinión de
alguna otra persona ahí es cuando los
sistemas educativos de todos los países
las universidades en general tenemos que
concentrarnos en la formación de
nuestros adultos o de los jóvenes y de
los adultos a la vez
entonces
eso puede ser una de las cosas que no
nos ayuda muchísimo al acceso de la
información a la vez cómo ha cambiado la
educación remota hoy por hoy en todos
nuestros países antes era dificilísimo
tener acceso a la educación en otros
lugares
hoy por hoy yo puedo ir y tomar una
clase en china desde mi casa perla desde
mi celular sin ningún problema me puedo
matricular
hay unas universidades que ahora no son
ni tan costosas las clases clases por
dos mil pesos un semestre y las puedo
tomar en línea y en universidades en
cualquier parte del mundo no le dan a
uno esa oportunidad entonces esa
educación remota que para uno antes era
por radio
si alguien quería educarse y no tenía
acceso a una escuela un colegio cercano
hacia educación por radio para los
millennials radio son unos prácticos así
cuadrados
tienen antenas
después les explico entonces esa
educación ahora remota es una cosa
increíble porque uno puede participar
oír opiniones de expertos tomar esa
información y aprender muchísimo esta
nueva generación tiene unas cosas que
nos ha generado muchísimos cambios en el
aspecto social de la gente pues qué pasa
yo tengo tres hijas mis hijas entre las
remotas son inquietos trabajar con ellas
ellas en una ciudad hay o en otra y en
cambiar mensajes en hacer proyectos se
vuelven práctica es increíble pero el
problema que tenemos es más la
interacción social persona a persona
porque porque como estamos tan
conectados se nos olvida la persona que
está al lado de nosotros ese problema lo
tenemos todos pero a nivel remoto
trabajamos transforma increíble entonces
esa globalización nos está ayudando
muchísimo nosotros como empleadores
como educadores donde tenemos que
trabajar muchísimo es en ese aspecto
social con nuestra nueva generación es
como los invitamos a que participen que
suelten el aparato por 5 segundos y se
comuniquen
porque tenemos que crear ese ambiente de
trabajo nos dan lecciones de trabajar a
nivel remoto y tienen una cosa súper
interesante que esta generación
esta generación cree en el medio
ambiente es una de esas generación que
nos va a ayudar a llevar este mundo a
hacer más que lo que estamos todos
buscando y con todo el conocimiento que
tienen de lo que está pasando en el
mundo es lo que nos está ayudando como
ellos tienen tanto acceso a la
información nos dan lo que nosotros
realmente necesitamos pero les voy a
contar un poquito de lo que va a cambiar
ahora en este mundo y según yo y según
muchos de los expertos con los que hemos
hablado cuáles son las cosas que vienen
a nivel de salud a nivel de salud tienen
muchísimas cosas con esta tecnología ya
las estamos utilizando monitores para
adultos mayores gente que está enferma
dentro de su casa en el cual los médicos
es recibiendo toda la información que
necesitan
para poder cuidar al paciente sin tener
que estar con ellos antes tenía uno que
esperar para ir al hospital hacer una
fila de tres días tres horas sentarse en
una silla todo ese tipo de cosas hoy por
hoy con ciertos monitores van a poder
mirar eso hay ciertas compañías a nivel
de salud que ya están hasta curando y
diagnosticando curas para heridas basado
en las fotos que están tomando los
celulares en que le mandan el mensaje al
médico y el médico básicamente puede
casi tratarlos darles la información de
lo que necesitan hacerle y la persona se
puede básicamente hacer la curación
dependiendo de qué tan grave esté
otra las compras la forma en cómo
compramos cómo subimos productos ha
cambiado totalmente no sé si ustedes
conozcan no algo así como amazon aquí en
mercadolibre también con cualquier
locales en las que cuales estamos
intercambiando productos constantemente
sin tener que ir a las tiendas y los
almacenes entonces nuestro mundo está
cambiando en inciaron amazon acaba de
montar una tienda que no tiene personal
no hay personal dentro de la tienda lo
único que hacen es esto la llena en el
stock por las noches pero uno va al
supermercado normalmente agarra el
cartón a metiendo las cosas dentro del
carrito y cuando sale le cobra
sin tener que tener contacto con ningún
ser humano es una cosa increíble porque
ya el acceso a este tipo de cosas se
está volviendo muchísimo más fácil a
medida que lo estamos probando
el transporte va a cambiar obviamente de
por si ahora ir al aeropuerto ya no
estamos usando casi ni papel para
chequear no si para viajar no todo lo
hace uno con el celular problemas que se
le acaba la pila cuando está llegando y
el paso a bordo se borra pero fuera de
eso no tiene uno ningún problema y con
los vuelos la información y el
transporte terrestre y todo ese tipo de
cosas y aún no sabe en qué momento llega
el camión el momento va a salir cómo va
a estar entonces eso le va a dar o no
mucho más tiempo y más facilidades en el
hogar lo mismo no tanto que vaya a meter
un aparato en la nevera y le diga como
que o en el refrigerador y le diga qué
es lo que le hace falta pero si ya hay
tecnología dentro de los refrigeradores
secadoras todas estas cosas que le dan a
uno cuando va a necesitar mantenimiento
antes de que necesite el mantenimiento
antes de que se dañe
básicamente entonces va a poder uno
prever
y ese tipo de cosas en el trabajo lo que
les digo el acceso remoto el cambiar las
cosas mundanas que tiene uno que hacer
las cosas repetitivas y poner robots a
que las hagan te va a ayudar a uno
muchísimo para que la gente realmente
haga trabajos que tengan un significado
más profundo en el día a día
finalmente el concepto de inteligencia
artificial la inteligencia artificial es
algo que está generando muchísimos
misterios dentro del día a día de la
gente de cómo vivimos muchísimos dicen
no la inteligencia artificial va a ser
un problema para todos te va a quitar
los puestos a todos los seres humanos
nos van a reemplazar todos los robots y
mi mundo como es hoy se va a acabar les
va a quitar ese misterio en un par de
cosas básicas hablando con con muchos
profesores de universidades muy
importantes a nivel mundial una de las
cosas que nos dicen es básicamente
dentro de 10 ó 15 años no va a haber
suficiente gente
para trabajar vamos a necesitar la
inteligencia artificial porque la
población del mundo no está creciendo
nosotros pensamos que ésta ha crecido
pero no nos estamos reemplazando ustedes
miran las familias en el pasado teníamos
no yo tengo mis abuelitos por ejemplo
les va a dar un ejemplo ellos tuvieron
diez hijas no siete hijas y tres picos'
pues tuvieron diez yo ya voy en tres
el mundo está cambiando no nos estamos
reemplazando lo suficiente y entonces
vamos a necesitar de la inteligencia
artificial para que nos ayude con esos
trabajos mundanos para que hagan las
cosas más fáciles y no tengamos que
hacer 30 cosas para hacer una cosa no
entonces tiene muchísimas cosas de
inteligencia artificial en países como
china por ejemplo hoy por hoy
el sistema de transporte o lo de
transportar comidas a las ciudades más
grandes como lo es la ciudad de méxico
aquí
en china en pekín ya tienen muchísimos
muchísimos carritos de repartición de
comida que se van recargando utilizando
inteligencia artificial y están enviando
la comida pero no hay y enviándola es
son son carritos que van por toda la
ciudad entregando las comidas para la
gente y se van auto cargando dentro de
la ciudad entonces eso son cosas que la
inteligencia artificial nos está dando
hoy por hoy y vamos al siguiente slide
nos quiero dejar con una con una frase
muy importante de mark zuckerberg y marc
habla de este
de esta cosa de inteligencia artificial
de como la gente lo está viendo en el
mundo entonces aquí lo que nos dice
básicamente es miren
las cosas se pueden utilizar para bien o
para mal uno depende de qué quiere hacer
entonces para no llevarlos muy
profundamente dentro de la inteligencia
artificial es yo puedo utilizar dos
piedras para crear candela
para ser fuego o puedo utilizar dos
piedras
para pegarle a alguien
yo escojo qué voy a hacer con eso lo
mismo es este misterio de la
inteligencia artificial
la gente dice vamos a utilizar la
inteligencia artificial para hacerle
daño a la gente la tecnología no está ni
está pensada para hacerle daño a la
gente la idea de la inteligencia
artificial y de lo que viene en el
futuro para ayudar a la gente es mejorar
el mundo en el que estamos y evitar que
sigamos destruyendo lo que estamos
destruyendo a nivel de ecológico lo que
estamos haciendo con nuestra gente hoy
por hoy la idea es que la inteligencia
artificial la tecnología el acceso a las
redes todo esto que estamos creando
desde igualdad a la gente igualdad al
acceso a información
igualdad a la educación y que podamos
seguir siendo y mejorando este mundo en
el que estamos y que la idea de todos
es dejar este mundo un poquito mejor de
lo que estaba atrás
[Música]